[Music]
[Music]
good evening good evening and welcome to
the Barnes normal Upper East Side thank
you so much for coming out here on a
lovely little brisk spring evening we
appreciate you guys being here if you
could all just please take one moment
and take a look at your cell phones and
please make sure that they are turned
off we would appreciate that
so following today's reading and
question an answer immediately
afterwards you will find me outside of
the glass doors we've got plenty of
books available for purchase including
one even newer than today's like my
teacher always said great graduation Day
gift we've got them outside as well
and afterwards Erin would be more than
happy to sign them for you up here I'm
sure so we are very happy to invite up
in the guest category for a change our
guest this evening when she is not
running the first line of defense
upstairs the customer service here at
the Barnes & Noble Upper East Side or
serving as bouncer during our Broadway
events a role of which let me tell you
she is most effective that she this
publishing executive is busy writing
award-winning books and we are delighted
tonight to present one of her latest
political suicide missteps pick Adela's
once the last time you use that word bad
calls backroom hijinks sorted past
rotten breaks and just plain dumb
mistakes in the annals of American
politics and with this crazy election
season I am certain that there will be a
sequel following this one
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming my colleague Aaron McKie
hi everybody thanks for coming out so
happy to see you all for any of you that
don't know me I was briefly from late
Monday night to early Tuesday morning
Ted Cruz's Secretary of State a couple
of years ago you know for those of you
who don't know how long it takes to get
a book published it's usually a couple
of years you have an idea you somebody
out somebody out to sell it a lot of
people say no a few people people say
yes finally it's got a home and then you
have to write it so I knew that 2016 the
election was coming and that it was
going to be sort of crazy but who could
possibly have any idea how crazy so with
that I think we all know what the what
landscape has been what it's only going
to turn out to be we don't know but as
mr. Obama said at the Correspondents
Dinner this the other night this is my
last time up here and we don't know who
she will be who serves up here next year
so we'll see anyway I'm gonna read the
introduction to you and a few pieces you
may have to stop me because they are all
these people are so crazy
you can hardly imagine that this all has
happened before we were born most of
them like that some some of the people
some of the pieces started as early as
the 1700s I will read one from somebody
who is presently in jail and got in
trouble around 2010 and in between in
the 21st century it seems that the
electoral process from our local school
board elections to campaigns for mayor
and congressmen to the selection of the
next president of our 50 States has
become a circus remember I wrote this a
year ago
but should be a series of thoughtful
activity on which the future of the
country rests is instead filled with
budgetary tightropes routines sparkly
partisan costumes ethical disappearing
acts and most certainly clowns instead
it becomes three rings of horror
we're so fatigued by the time the mud is
flung the old skeletons have come out of
the closet an election day is over that
we're often exhausted by our new
legislators before they've even had this
chance to start their jobs the loom is
already off the roads the thrill is gone
and they haven't even had a chance to
screw it up yet oh but they will not all
of them of course but enough to keep the
headlines filled in the 24-hour news
programming churning enough fulness up
to make us wish we had voted for
somebody else or to wonder how could he
think he could get away with that and
we'll sit back and shake our heads we'll
say to each other
now that is political suicide but so
often it doesn't bring them out to baby
you can understand it anyway so let me
read a few of our favorite pieces this
is about a man named Robert Potter he
lived from 1802 1842 so not so long
Robert Potter was a seafaring lad from
North Carolina entering the United
States Navy in ninety in 1815 when he
was fifteen years old
and staying in his admit Shipman until
he was 21 in those days life at sea
provided plenty of excitement from
keeping on the lookout for pirates to
policing the slave trade he may have
left the Navy because he was discouraged
or not being promoted or as legend had
it he may have gotten sacked because he
killed an officer in a duel there are
lots of tools
lots of do you think of only you know
that Alexander Hamilton and Aaron Burr
duels everywhere either way it was back
to the land lubber life in law school
for potter who passed the bar at 1823 he
then into Congress and his congressional
congressional career as a Tar Heel
was even shorter than his time on the
bounding main because of one summer
afternoon in 1831 Robert Potter
castrated two men I know
what afternoon Potter was certain that
his wife Isabella was stepping out on
him with two very different bows one a
minister and the other teenage boy some
reports say that mrs. Potter had kept
her fares all her affairs all in the
family that the minister was her cousin
and the boy was the nephew of her
stepmother but that's never been
confirmed what is known is that Potter
attacked them both on the same day the
particulars are sort of sketchy but
reports of what assaults say that when
Potter found Isabella and the Reverend
in a buggy together he roped the man of
God around the neck pulled him onto the
ground hogtied him and then cut him down
below as for the congressman he was
remorseful but seemingly at peace with
his actions he declared I am consoled by
the conviction that in what I have done
I've only acted upon those feelings
which Nature has implanted in the hearts
of all men indeed I may say of all the
animals and that each of you would have
done the same thing under the same
circumstances well maybe maybe not
people may disagree with Potter's choice
of punishment but they certainly have
not forgotten congressman Potter's
adventures with the knife even today
castration or the threat of it which is
surely much more common it's still
called part pot arising in parts of the
south following the incidents part of
resign from Congress in November of 1831
and he and his wife divorced no surprise
there
he paid a three thousand dollar fine has
spent six months in pregnant prison he
did manage to get voted back into the
legislature but the next year got tossed
out for an episode that involved a card
game and other shady dealings which may
have been cheating British singer gun or
a knife stealing money or try to get in
trying to get out of a debt take your
pick
those were all the reports and Potter
decided then it was time to move to
Texas now let me just say here there was
a lot of moving around because of course
there was no 24-hour news cycle and not
a lot of you know newspaper coverage and
such back then that when you got in
trouble you would just move far far away
where people had never heard of you so
he decided he was going to move to tack
the Wild West seemed to get to better
agree with the ruffian couldn't
congressman he got some military
credibility back and even ended up
signing the Tecla Texas Declaration of
Independence he took up with a new woman
whom he married though she still seemed
to have a husband somewhere and he
served a Secretary of the Navy in Texas
the Texas Navy and even wormed his way
back into the Texan Congress but perhaps
Carter Potter had not heard back quite
enough karma points in 1842 during a
little-known Texas feud known as the
regulator moderator war Potter found his
home surrounded by members of the enemy
regulators he thought he could get away
by jumping into a nearby lake and
escaped by swimming underwater to safety
but he came up for air and the minute he
did he was shot in the head he's buried
in Texas and has a double-sided
gravestone with one side highlighting
his political achievements of North
Carolina achievements and on the other
side Texas so colorful
to say the least right
here's a man named Marion Tucker crazy
people in Washington his name is Marion
Zion check he lived from 1901 only to
1936 born in Poland in 1901 Marion Zion
check was but a tot when his family
moved to the United States and settled
in Seattle Washington there he
eventually entered politics politics
first as a left-leaning college student
and then as a New Deal Democrat by 1932
at the age of only 31 he ran for
Congress and into the hallowed halls of
Washington in 1990 1933 early on Zion
Tech showed great promise he was
energetic and interested in reform and
eager and steady worker and a stalwart
advocate for the great depressions
forgotten man
he seemed high-spirited but much of it
was chalked up to youthful enthusiasm
after all he was a bachelor new to the
nation's capital and he had the world to
conquer but the truth was that he was
probably bipolar something that would
likely be more quickly diagnosed today
but remained untreated in this
congressman it began with pranks and
partying though excessive his behavior
was hardly unique but by 1936 the
stories and the attendant arrests were
multiplying
he made ways for publicly referring to
the Supreme Court justices as old
fossils he hosted one legendary New
Year's Eve party where the council Cole
called only defined when they arrived to
investigate the noise complaint the Zion
check had taken over the building
switchboard and was calling up all of
the neighbors he was also arrested for
speeding down Connecticut Avenue Avenue
at seventy miles an hour which must been
hired in a car in the 30s it seems to me
not only did he resist arrest but he
tried to run out of the courtroom a
partner appeared before the judge and
was cited for contempt and then he found
a girlfriend a Works Progress
Administration secretary named Ruby
Louise Nix she didn't remain a
girlfriend for long they married in a
jiffy unwilling to wait for three days
for papers to clear in the District of
Columbia they hopped in the car and I'm
sure sped to Maryland
hitched when the groom didn't have the
two bucks of the license he borrowed
from the justice of the peace
reporters were thrilled of course Zion
shock would have become their new go-to
guy for headlines and this one was a
winner before departing for his
honeymoon his eyen check hosted a small
coterie of journalists in his apartment
he mixed cocktails what things were made
out of hair tonic and gin or something
while wearing an Indian headdress and
entertaining inquiries when asked how he
met and married his bride so quickly he
explained I met her about a week ago
when she called me up one night she
asked me down and so I went down and
looked her over she was okay
ain't love grand Zion Chicken Ruby then
took off to Puerto Rico for a honeymoon
where more wildness ensued Zion took
gotten two separate car accidents
including one where he bit the driver on
the neck and caused the car to crash in
a ditch he also apparently has cited a
small political riot that got out of
hand so much so that he was forced to
call the Marines to intervene things
were really getting out of hand and it
didn't help that he was allegedly
tossing back the rum and hair tonic
cocktails with some abandoned so upon
returning to the mainland Zions had
continued his downward spiral one
afternoon he drove to the White House
into the driveway which as you could do
anybody could do then with some gifts
for his aisle gifts FDR the president
unfortunately wasn't home Bisaya neck
wrote a little note left it behind the
driveway along with the bag holding a
collection of empty beer bottles
mothballs and ping pong balls
later that day Zion check was arrested
and brought to a sanitarium
he escaped us seems like it's sort of
you know finally he escaped several days
later and was picked up again by the
police Ruby had him transferred to a
different hospital from which we again
escaped and was arrested and brought
back to gain his freedom sign a check
voluntarily returned to his hometown of
Seattle
rather than risk imprisonment in DC back
in Seattle he found that you'll already
have quite a fan club it seemed that
people nationwide had loved the crazy
stories of what he was being called
which is the capital clown and none so
more than the residents of his home
district they embraced his craziness it
wasn't real as if anybody had gotten
hurt except I guess maybe the guy bitten
on the neck the guy was just a nut when
giant check told his constituents he
would not run for re-election a friend
filed papers to run for his seat and
then suddenly science agreed to reverse
this decision and said he would run
again however he'd never see the
campaign on their way to a gala Ruby and
her husband stopped by his offices in
downtown Seattle while ruby stayed in
the car zion check one upstairs wrote a
suicide note and then stepped off the
ledge of his window on the fifth floor I
don't
his body struck the ground right next to
the card which ruby was sat waiting for
him they hastily scrawled suicide note
written on his official letterhead said
my only hope in life was to improve the
condition of an unfair economic system
that held no promise to those that all
the wealth of even a decent chance to
survive let alone live was it because
his friend had threatened to take his
seat or was it really a culmination of
growing mental instability we'll never
know but Zion Scheck still holds the
record for being the only sitting
congressman ever sent to an insane
asylum
think about that yes we should say I
guess yet okay I would like to read to
you the story of reader crunch well my
favorite story in the book she's still
alive born in 1953 this is the biggest
embezzlement scam that you have never
heard of
in fact Rita crime laws case is the
biggest municipal fraud in American
history and it took place a little dot
on the map known as Dixon Illinois
before crown robot brought it into the
spotlight Dixon was most famous for
being Ronald Reagan's childhood home
that's about it the town had just three
full-time employees and Rita was one as
current controller and treasurer the
majority of employees were part-time and
held other jobs to keep their financial
heads above water for example the male
mayor made $9,000 and he had a Cadillac
showroom somewhere on earth Grunwald
started as a secretary to the mayor
right out of high school in 1974 and was
appointed to her City Financial Post in
1983 it was a sweet deal for her
Kronwall was a horse lover and
eventually became what was one one of
the best horse breeder horse quarter
horse breeders in the country her equine
business took up several months a year
on the road going off to horse shows and
the like it was certainly more that her
paid four weeks of vacation allowed but
the small town control I had a luxury
motor home she traveled around and all
tricked out and it was dense you
generally uncalled-for her town duties
even if she was away the folks that dig
Dixon figured they had a pretty good
deal as Rita doctor'll pay every day she
took a day off and was still available
for work by phone or email that's there
Rita this is you know these are all her
neighbors and friends no one was quite
sure how Cranwell afforded the fancy
motor home and the swanky horse farm in
addition to some pricey clothes furs
jewelry and all this under eighty-three
thousand dollar annual salary don't
forget - all the days that she was being
unpaid for taking the day off
but everybody knew she sold lots of
horses they figured that that's where
all her money came from and the three
homes she owned others assumed that
she'd inherited money from somewhere
despite the fact that the townspeople
knew her parents who are local people
are not at all wealthy this is a perfect
instance of people seeing what they
wanted to they believe she was
trustworthy she was one of them and so
they didn't question it
therefore he came as quite a shock but
in 2011 Kathi Swanson Colonels assistant
discovered a strange bank account when
she was covering at the office during
one of her own wells many absences an
account that had been opened back in
1998 it was the city of Dixon was the
primary account holder and the secondary
account holder
Rita Kronwall this scam was fairly
simple crime drug would draw up fake
invoices oftentimes misspelling just on
a typewriter she would like this felt
town and Illinois and things like this
so she would drop the fake invoices then
transfer the money from the legitimate
city of Dixon bank account and deposited
it into the dummy account any audit any
on at all in 30 years would have
uncovered this scam but no one ever
checked why would they
this was Rita she worked for the town
for them all these years and so she got
away with writing nearly 200 of these
fake invoices for road repairs and other
items in addition to checks from the
city account to her the rscd a her
account that were made out directly to
treasurer even some of the checks were
made out to equestrian facilities and
spas and they escaped attention since no
one was watching
no one was noticing so it started small
but in a few years after opening the
account
Rita Kronwall was making checks out to
fairly large amounts like three hundred
thousand five hundred thousand dollars
over the course of year the many years
all these 30 years sit down I hope
you're all sitting Rita cron will sold
fifty three million dollars from the
town of Dixon Illinois
right out of the pockets of her friends
and neighbors at the same time that she
was filling her coffees the city of
Dixon IVA couldn't afford the most basic
repairs and updates I know the police
had cars that all these old used radios
there were streets that badly needed
repair there was a water treatment
facility that didn't get built
when Swanson the secretary found the
dummy account
she was floored she was Rita after all
she immediately brought it to the
attention of the mayor who wasted no
time in calling the FBI six months later
they were ready and one morning in April
2012 Rio Grande wells called in to Mayor
Burke's office where the FBI was waiting
for her Rita confessed after all she was
caught red-handed
there was nothing much she could do and
she fully cooperated with the FBI this
is not in the book but my favorite part
is the mayor was so upset by now when
asked on what his you know his thoughts
his comments on the on the episode was
he said turned out reader crying well
didn't give a [ __ ] about this down
[Laughter]
during sentencing your lawyer asked for
leniency said that she would have to
endure shame and disrepute for the rest
of her life but the former trusted
small-town employee was sent away for 20
years Dixon Illinois had paid for three
decades of criminals luxurious lifestyle
and now she would have to pay the price
she is due for release in 2030 so that's
the story of Rita this is a rather newer
story mm I have to read it because of
the Diaries you'll see you many of you
remembered Bob Packwood born in 1932 so
here we go and he got in trouble later
in the last century but interesting
stuff Senator Bob Packwood came from a
long line of politicians dating back to
1857 when his great-grandfather was part
of the Aragon constitutional convention
packwood took up the family trade as an
energetic Republican in his home state
of Oregon playing party [ __ ]
meeting it making a name for himself
back in 1963 at the age of 29 he entered
the Oregon House of Representatives and
just five years later after a squeaker
of a race with a longtime incumbent he
won the race for the United States
Senate fact we came to Washington as a
youngest senator in town a socially
moderate Republican who supported civil
rights gun control and legalized
abortion and won accolades for many
women's groups including PAC Planned
Parenthood and the National Women's
Political caucus he and his wife Georgy
were popular breath of fresh air
packwood worked tirelessly to ingratiate
himself into the political system and by
1985 he replaced daniel patrick moynihan
as chairman of the powerful Senate
committee of finance finance he was now
one of the most powerful men in
Washington but he was also a massive
drinker before his 1980 Senate campaign
his wife Georgy finally talked him into
seeking a therapist and talking to them
her about it he returned from the
appointment and reportedly declared I am
NOT an alcoholic I thought I have what
is called the drinking problem so this
raid continued board of executives later
in 1992 it all began to come apart and
PAC would certainly wouldn't be getting
any more kudos from women's groups
instead he was getting hit with charges
of sexual harassment many of his victims
were staff members or lobbyists the
former often just left his employ to
avoid the problem the weird thing you
remember back in the day when you
couldn't get away with speaking up there
were anything about the allegations that
were coming to light is that packwood
really didn't understand what the
problem was it seemed he say awkward
things like I'm apologizing for the
conduct that is what is alleged that I
did it was the non-denial denial as
Woodward and Bernstein would have said
of all the accusers the worst indictment
of PAC was bad behavior came from
packwood himself we know plenty about
what he thought and did during this year
these years because I just loved this so
much
he kept a diary
a diary that sounded like it belonged to
a teenage girl in 1993 that died you
know I know this is all the so
disgusting but the diary just really
gets me the diary was subpoenaed by the
Senate Ethics to get a committee and by
1995 excerpts appeared in every major
newspaper across the country
my favorite sample although disgusting
of his extremely odd and unsettling
grasp of sexual behavior crabs
Tracy Gorman behind the Xerox machine
today as she got a little pissed what's
the big deal I was smiling while I did
it she made this big stink about it and
it took me about two hours and a couple
of thousand dollars to calm her down I
have one question if she didn't want me
to feather her nest why did she come
into the Xerox room sure she is that old
excuse that she had to make copies of
the Brady mill but if you believe that I
have a roomful of radical feminists you
can box she knew I was copying stuff in
there I had my jacket off and my sleeves
rolled up revealing the well-defined
musculature of my sinewy arms which are
always bulging with desire I know what
she wanted this didn't require a lot of
thought
Boyet it came to lighten the time
between the start of this misconduct
into the investigation and the release
of his diary of the committee packwood
had gone back and changed and deleted
portions of the record even crazier if
possible
he confessed in the diary about making
the changes this torturous political
drama went on until 1995 when packwood
was resigned under immense pressure from
the Senate Georgia by the way had left
him in 1991 he went back to Oregon if
you wonder he course has some big
lobbying for him somewhere
let me read two more one more two more
okay
we had cousin yeah you know it's hard to
hard to not read about Wilbur Mills 1909
to 1992
much of caught you know when you do
something like this and you do the
research you're always looking for the
one fact or you've never heard before
you digging you dig and you dig and you
dig and when I get to the last line of
this one you'll see what I find out my
favorite much of congressman will Wilbur
Mills his life the majority in fact is
stamped with good deeds a fine
congressional record and finally
redemption but as an all downfall so
those years are never the dishing part
of the story
Mills was Democrat from Arkansas from a
family of liberals his father was a
school superintendent who helped to
integrate Wilbur's public school which
was the first one in the state to teach
both black and white students
valedictorian of his high school in
solitary and Salah to torreón of in
cotton college young Wilbur
that went on to Harvard Law School and
at last in 1939 at age 30 he ended up in
Washington he became an extremely
powerful voice in Washington and
remained in Congress for nearly four
decades from 1939 to 1977 seventeen of
those years were spent as the chairman
of the House Ways and Means Committee to
this day no one has ever held the chair
lager he helped develop Medicare as
medical aid for the pro-poor was an
early interest for him back in his
Arkansas days in fact Mills the senator
Ted Kennedy had also been working
previously
on the Kennedy Mills universal
healthcare reform bill in the summer of
1974 which Mills managed to get through
the Ways and Means Committee with a
little squeaker of a 13 12 vote with
such a narrow margin wills was nervous
about bringing the bill to the House
floor but that became a moot question
just a few months later on the morning
of October 9 Wilbur Mills his life as
your mother would say went to hell in a
handbasket when his car was stopped by
police at 2:00 a.m. for driving with no
headlights on
he was drunk his glasses are broken cuz
law like this he cuts all over his face
and he was in the company of a stripper
well I'll remember a stripper who jumped
out of the car and ran into the title
basin in what the cops would later call
a half-hearted suicide of it attempt
they brought it to the mental unit for
the night but it gets juicier Mills
claims she was a Washington neighbor a
mrs. Annabel BETT Estella originally of
Argentina and all of that was certainly
true but she was more famously known as
Fannie Fox a dancer at the Silver
Slipper where she was known as the
Argentine firecracker Wilbur had a
further excuse about the whole evening
as reported in The Washington Post
my wife's bookends broken foot prevented
our entertaining at home and says she
insisted I take our friends to a public
place we had frequented before this I
did he explained we visit another place
and had a few refreshments mrs. pett
Estella became ill and I had listed the
help of others in our group to assist me
in seeing her safely home since bills
looked beaten up and Fannie Fox ended up
in the mental hospital perhaps she sort
of asked for a better host of course the
real story was that Fannie and Wilbur
had been canoodling already for some
time and according to people who saw
them regularly down at the Silver
Slipper altercations and arguments were
far from unusual but in those pre social
media days no one ever nabbed a serve to
serve dishes photo of them or reported
any hanky-panky at all certainly not
online
in fact Mills managed to lay low for
just a few days after the arrest
claiming that the whole thing was a
string
unfortunate circumstances evidently
brought on by a few refreshments he
ultimately holed up just for a week and
that thing seemed to die down then on
November 4th he won re-election is 60%
of the vote they might have not heard
about a lot of this guy in Arkansas it
might have just ended they're just a
lone suspicious tawdry incident but it
didn't when Fanny was playing a joint in
Boston just a few weeks later and
obviously drunken Wilbur Mills toddled
on stage gave her a kiss and then says
that wasn't enough game press conference
back in her dressing room enough was
enough for the waves of Means Committee
and Mills was asked to step down as
chairman to his credit Wilbur Mills
redeemed himself personally if not
politically he joined a a decided not to
run him for re-election and went into
private law practice when he retired in
1991 he returned to Arkansas and
established the will Verde Mills
treatment center not much more was heard
about a universal health care reform
bill until Hillary Clinton proposed one
in 1993 now how what happened to the
Argentine firecracker she eventually
returned to South America
here it is during a 1980 74 interview
with Bill O'Reilly shortly before she
left she confessed a desire to go to
medical school and who knows perhaps one
could still make a private appointment
with dr. Fannie Fox a boy in a series
[Laughter]
okay last one I don't know if anybody
remembers this yet a Bronstein
no good Janna Bronstein was use smart
honest fair and devoted to the American
Way she was no nonsense
she had no criminal past in fact what
she stood for made a lot of sense when
she ran for president in 1964
hurray she lost the she herself admitted
in a landslide
mrs. Bronstein made perfect sense it is
time for the country to have a mother
she insisted if a mother was in the
White House we would look to the
presidency with more respect she
proposed plain talk proposals with the
abolishment of income taxes in favor of
each member of the family weighing in on
or before April 15 and paying $5 per
pound including pets her platform
included some campaign promises and
ideas that were popular then and would
likely be appreciated by the emember
American public in a candidate today
mrs. Bronstein White House bid on the
best party ticket boasted a
straightforward catchy slogan vote for
Janna and things will get better
there were accompanying Flyers buttons I
hope you all got a button out of the
front door media coverage and a campaign
poster with yetta's picture on it but
despite a fair amount of media coverage
of her campaign throughout the 1964
presidential race no one ever saw the
candidate in person no one ever saw her
because yet it didn't actually exist it
turned out that Yetta was a hoax
revealed at last in 1966 before she got
too involved in her candidacy for 1968
she was the creation of Alan Abel who
builds himself as a prophetic
professional media hoaxer and his wife
Jean in Wakeeney who did the hundreds of
newspaper and phone interviews
pertaining a Jewish mother from the
Bronx the photo of Yetta used in her
campaign materials was actually Alan's
mother Ida and still like any savvy
politician yet I went on to write a book
the president I also was published in
1966 a memoir of her presidential dreams
vintage copies are still available
online yet a prosti did not go gently
into that good night and a letter to
Barack Obama in 2009
she offered the president a few of her
proposals free of charge
take Congress off salary and put them on
straight Commission charge $5,000 for a
marriage license and $5 for a no-fault
divorce employee a metal detector in the
White House as well as a metal detector
national bingo and truth serum in the
Senate drinking fountain oh yeah
we hardly knew you thank you very much
[Applause]
any questions comments
you're bowled over right yes I have to
go to dinner but I'm gonna buy your SSI
did you just sit there and say
I mean you knew what was going to be
it's it's always crazy and as time goes
on and the media gets you know the kids
feels like they can't fit all the junk
they have to say in 24 hours you know
that they're just going to be looking
for things and to to cover but they
could just sit in their seat and it all
comes to them it's just you know I don't
think we can ever ever have seen all of
this coming the behavior yes you know I
think I started finding lifts in places
like googling and Wikipedia and stuff
like that and then you had to go back to
the library there's so much more than
you would think yeah there I said that
to somebody else a microfiche in Xerox
is a scrolling and scrolling stuff
there's a lot of things you know
obituaries and congressional records and
things like that that you know you
wouldn't think existed that do so it's
it's out there but boy do you have to
you have to work to get through it I'll
tell you yes the latest scandal I heard
was with Ted Cruz in college Rachel
Maddow was um was talking about it that
he was had like really creepy behaviors
in the dorm rooms I don't know this is
like like company how much and say but
he was doing like weird stuff and do you
know anything about that or what do you
think I don't think much about that but
you know it's interesting one of the
people I wrote about in the book is Lee
Atwater who you might remember from the
from the 80s and he was you'd think now
of him is one of the first sort of duty
trick players you know and he would
start one of the things he did at the
very beginning of his he was responsible
for the whole Willie Horton thing when
and and having Mike Dukakis lose any
sort of credence with everybody when in
fact that whole weekend furlough stuff
was a Massachusetts law before Dukakis
was even in office so
you know you get people head up about
things and once you get it in the media
it doesn't matter whether it's true or
not is the unfortunate thing you have
the time you know yeah since the first
president obviously a lot has changed
it's still changing today what do you
think is the standard today first is
back know versus back then I guess I
want to say back then being since the
first president was elected what is the
standard for political suicide well that
you like for me it was that you were at
fault for losing your own position you
know whether there's babes or booze or
embezzlement or whatever it was you got
in your own way and managed to screw up
you know what you've worked so hard for
as for that and that's the end what you
bring up is a good question do you think
all of you in the room I don't know what
whether things were worse before or now
obviously we don't know a lot of things
that happened before because the media
was not so broad we've I found a lot of
a lot of the things that I that I
uncovered that when something like like
the like Senator Potter from when he
moved to Texas that people just want if
they went far far away people just
didn't know who they were they didn't
know whether they had been up and what
they were up against one guy went to
California made a new start and he was
kicked out of California that's far this
as far as you can get from here it's
still you know still be running for
office yes
[Music]
thank you and reflective of the
selections that are in the book I do
pictures a few gems yes because there's
something in the political personality
that sort of leads people to their own
destruction that's a good question and
here would be my question back to you do
you think there's something in people
that leaves them to politics you know is
there something in your DNA that leads
you to politics and I guess what we will
never know about each particular
politician is what their end game is
when they enter how much of it is for
the public how much is how much is it
for their you know
so satisfaction hard to say yeah your
sense of invincibility which allows you
then to go and pull some of this stuff I
think that I think that's I think that's
how it all works that they are
absolutely right when you think of the
reader cranwell story and and how she
started stealing money it's always one
of those things you still five dollars
and then next week it's easier just til
ten and next thing you know is fifty
three million dollars I think that you
get lost in your own power you believe
you people start believing their own
stories although they are probably
mostly mythical I can name one candidate
that's a point time to be in November I
don't know I mean you keep thinking you
know now that he is you for those of for
those people who are afraid of Trump you
think now that he is out of sort of
primary mode and into general election
mode that he is calming down and that he
might be able to keep it together but I
really just I really just can't believe
that that will happen every day
every day I think something is gonna
happen so we'll see because he's really
you know he is the top of the heap when
it comes to somebody you think of gotta
put local suicide yeah did you happen to
touch on Anthony's Wiener I I decided
although I did you know for Peter Kern
was in jail so or the end of her story
is pretty clear I stayed away from
people who are currently in the press
because again you know a book takes a
long time to come out and then you hope
it's around for a little while
so people's fortunes let's say change so
quickly that you don't know if they're
going to be in the news out of the news
if they have a future if somebody
forgets about them back they come who
knows so I stayed away from people who
are as I say presently in the news yeah
I was just wondering given the media is
so powerful now that if you were to
write up something similar to this with
current people like Weiner
how much would you have to incorporate
the power of the media it's not just
political suicide but how much the media
fits that's right and again you've got a
new thing back to somebody like Lee
Atwater who sort of led let the crime
and and so much of what goes on today's
when you're talking about news who's
watching Morning Joe today and they were
and Rob Reiner was on and he was right
in him I'll tell you talking about news
and features and how much was news and
how much was show how much was the you
know it's show business and for once Joe
Scarborough could hardly get a word in
edgewise so it was so it's hard to tell
you know I did manok it's I would say
the whole thing is fun to watch except
it's so scary to watch
for me his name escapes me but who
committed political suicide
like just say one word Canuck that was
question things considered a [ __ ] French
that's really what's you know we are now
almost 60 years later you have to do
something very very very bad to commit
political suicide doesn't any say
something that doesn't just say
something about our civilization I
absolutely think it does that's just my
opinion excuse me of course but it just
seems that things are way out of control
certainly in daily life I know I and the
first to complain about no one having
any manners so and it just goes on from
there up to you know I don't think the
White House but close to
all right well if you can run the
country yeah right right right well you
know because that builds on that builds
on I tried it in college but I didn't
inhale and then you know and then it's
it's it's like anything and then you can
just say one more step and one more step
and one more step and now you're on
stage talking about the size of your
member
[Music]
I'm sorry
I'll say Oh
[Music]
in the future saw the cops that were
yelled taking getting lavish lavish
gratuities and diamonds from you know
the two real estate developers in
Brooklyn and you know some high EPS work
you know stripped her their guns and
badges and reassigned it's also some of
them supposedly that we're working girls
on a yacht it's just something you would
start how long how much time would have
to elapse before you'd want to
investigate in something like Abscam
which is also an area you want to wait
till it is that you know so the a court
case has been settled as far as call
girls and diamonds and free donuts and
whatever else I suspect it was ever thus
playing the role and like what type of
politician goes for one kind of scandal
as like a Republican might go for they
tend to do these kind of scandals
Democrats might tend to do I didn't
notice that that's a good question
though I have to get an excel chart on
that question how do you feel about
Barack Obama's presidency
hello please thank you so much every day
ladies and gentlemen Erin McHugh we'd
like to thank you so much for coming out
here tonight I'll be once we get Erin
situated up here I'll be right through
the glass doors we've got books
available for purchase Erin would be
more than happy to sign any of them for
you thanks for much for coming out here
tonight please take your buttons when
you leave and there's a calendar of
events for the rest of May please pick
one of those up as well thanks again for
coming out here tonight we appreciate it
don't forget if the button say stupid
never sleeps
[Music]
[Music]
a lot